yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights
visit expressvpn.com yang
our safetynet um it was constructed to
be difficult to use
and lo and behold when you had a real
crisis in which people need to use
benefits um or safety net programs
that that then it you know the systems
can't contain these people
um and just in general i think that that
the government
uh is dysfunctional for a lot of reasons
but one of the ways in which the
government is dysfunctional
is that um it doesn't have a very good
customer service
orientation uh things like doing your
taxes are really confusing so miserable
yeah why right um because i think it's
in in a lot of ways intentional
right we don't want the government to
work very well um or at least a lot of
people i wanted i wanted to work well
annie
you do you know one of the things that
comes out of that is that in many ways
interacting with our government reduces
our
interest in and confidence in government
as you put it
and and there's even some evidence that
it sort of dissuades people from voting
and disconnects them from the political
process no way they're like i want
nothing to do with this
that's awful and i think that there is
this really interesting kind of like
thought loop that you get in in which
like
public services are terrible and it
erodes your confidence in government
and then it becomes self-justifying
right like why would we want to put any
more administration into this if the
government can't get anything right
like making government work for people
is is
not necessarily a focus of our political
system but it really should be
so the cops
who shot brianna taylor
were one was mildly punished is that a
fair way to give that headline
one was mildly punished and the rest are
free is is that an objectively
correct statement yes i believe the
charge brought was wanton
endangerment which is a fourth degree
felony
and i saw someone raise other fourth
degree felonies to give you a basis of
comparison
and another fourth degree felony is
using someone else's credit card for
between 500 and a thousand dollars
uh the penalty for
wanton endangerment is um up to five
years in jail
can be no jail time so it's a very mild
charge so
i want to make sure we level set what
happened
to brianna generally and then what
happened in the aftermath so
brianna was sleeping um
and because of a no-knock warrant rule
cops
busted in someone in her house fired and
then she was killed in crossfire did i
get that right
yeah that that is right and one of the
key facts that seems to have come up
is whether or not the cops announced
themselves
um and there's some dispute over this uh
the vast majority
seem to agree that they did not and then
there was one neighbor that
suggested that they did but the
general facts that everyone agrees on uh
the fact that brianna was sleeping in a
bed
uh and then was shot in the crossfire
between
the police and her boyfriend uh and
the the fact that the charges have
nothing to do with brianna taylor
herself is infuriating to many
um but the rules unfortunately
were really uh not designed to protect
people in their homes in this sort of
situation
because of the no knock warrant which in
my view is a bad rule
and louisville changed it uh other
jurisdictions should do the same because
you also simultaneously have something
called stand your ground laws
which is that if someone partisan
unannounced into your
home in particular you can use whatever
force
uh is available to you and and so if you
have
police barging in unannounced and stand
your ground laws you essentially are
saying
everyone can uh have at it and no one
can no one
is doing anything wrong uh in a country
where
firearms are so ubiquitous that that
does not seem like
uh like a sensible approach uh and so
no knock warrants in my mind are the
problem
and no knock warrants were not the law
of the land for
a long time there's uh and
the rationale behind them is that it
will keep criminals from being able to
destroy evidence
uh and provide uh
police officers like a higher margin of
safety if they can
barge in unannounced if they have reason
to believe that the person within
um will uh respond violently
so a no dog weren't just for any
listening because i didn't know what
this was it's it's a regular search
warrant but you do not need to do it the
cops do not legally need to announce
themselves
right and yeah that's right is that
and then your point is that if a cop
just burst down your door you as a
private citizen
are in your own legal right to start
shooting them and then once
the cops are shot at they are in their
legal right to shoot you back
so you now have and your point is that
you've essentially just legalized
gunfighting
to where at the end of the gunfight no
one's held accountable because
everybody's within their rights
and within the law is that is that a
correct summary
yeah that that's correct uh and
and to it i think to the objective
observer that's not
the situation you want uh and and so
you should to me uh curb no knock
warrants
have police announce themselves and then
if you are in
uh in a dwelling going to know it's a
police
officer and then you know you're you're
not going to
uh fire on them unless
unless frankly you have a death wish
because if you fire on them you're
probably going to be killed
so the the so that that gets rid of
um this perverse situation uh that
resulted in part in um
these charges that we're seeing right
now uh and it was one officer who
apparently fired
many extra shots uh into neighboring
apartments
that they said look this is um
criminal we can charge you with it but
the charge in the scheme of things
uh is infuriating to so many because it
has nothing to do with
brianna taylor lost her life
so you talk about
a major solution would be getting rid of
this law but i do see
very rational reasons where this law
would be great where if you're trying to
track down a serial killer or
someone who's con inflicted tons of harm
and they're tough to catch
you need the element of surprise you
don't want them to destroy computers by
announcing yourself they can escape they
can
do x y z how do you if you're gonna
legislate that how do you draw that line
right you just make it tougher to get a
no knock warrant you ban them all
together like
what do you structure that i'm not
convinced that the the utility of
that that window of time is so massive
in
an either direction because if you have
to announce yourself
uh and then enter like that doesn't mean
you're waiting for like 15 minutes while
they uh you know while they
destroy things or do whatnot like it can
simply be
like this is the police and then
you do what you're going to do anyway
and like what you used to announce
yourself clearly and then smash the door
down
uh you know to me that's like that
that's not like
this massive opportunity to um
to destroy evidence or or do whatever
but like that would be a small
price to pay in my mind for all of the
um the public safety benefits uh
and for the fact that you know that if
it's the police like they
should let you know which has been the
law of the land for a long time
like a no knock warrants a relatively
recent addition
uh it used to be essentially common law
inherited from england that if the
police come to your house they have to
let you know
is it is the no knock warrant law is it
state by state or is that federal
state by state it's state by state and
the stand your ground laws
are essentially the norm in the united
states uh like something like 35 states
at a 50 uh have it essentially it's like
everyone knows it's like a stand your
ground law uh zone i think it
i think idiots like me are thinking like
when they pictures in their head they're
thinking like uh
like you've seen like a cop movie where
they're like surrounding like an old
barn
where like this like hideout where a
villain is or like a criminal is
and they've got all this evidence in
there and at that point in that movie
scenario you want the element of
surprise right
but again again you can surround the
heck out of that barn
like movie style you can do it all
someone has to yell police before you
smash it down
you know like i mean that like that's
it's not it doesn't prevent you from
doing all the things that
you'd want to do the the other thing is
like
the my gut says if most of this crime
and these types of
individuals are living in bigger cities
you're talking about apartments
you're talking about nowhere to escape
um type scenarios
um where it is like a simple knock and
then there's no time to
you know do much um it's just just
someone yell police there's a police
open up and then
if the response then you go at it but at
least then there's no ambiguity that
the person legitimately just had their
door smashed in and then like
you know what are you gonna do if you're
asleep with your girlfriend it's
midnight
someone smashed the door down like you
know and you have a firearm i mean
like there are many many americans like
i saw online a social media post where
like it was uh someone said look
uh i'm white i'm a gun owner and if
someone smashed down my door like i'm
gonna fire on them immediately like that
that was like
the post which uh which to me
reflected the reality of the situation
so what's heartbreaking right now is
that there's so many literally millions
of americans
that want justice for her justice for
bianna
and right now they're not getting it
it doesn't look like they're going to
get it in that in this
when we say justice it means someone
needs to go to jail for murdering her
right somebody's paid the price
um and the reason i want to i want to
understand that it seems like to me the
reason
there's no justice for her no one's been
arrested for murder
murdering her is because no one
technically broke the law is that
correct
the rules as written would make it very
difficult to prosecute
these officers for murdering brianna
taylor that's correct
and that is what's heartbreaking and so
the real justice for her is to
we have to change the laws right like
that's yes
uh well not nothing can bring brianna
back to her family yes i mean
there's already been a successful civil
suit uh and
the the city pre-announced
essentially the uh the fact that they
settled with the family
um this is actually a norm in many
jurisdictions where if the police do
something
uh irreparable uh
no they maim someone or injure someone
then someone gets a settlement uh but
there's no
liability attached to the officers that
that's actually
a not uncommon um resolution which i
would suggest
is not what you want like you don't want
a country where
police officers make make mistakes at a
certain level
and then the victims or the victims
families get a certain amount of money
like that that not that is not where our
resources should be going i mean we're
spending over a billion dollars a year
right now
on uh payments to uh
victims and families uh you know it's
like i mean that that's
ridiculous like you know in some
jurisdictions you're paying hundreds of
millions of dollars
uh a year to victims and and their
families
uh so rules changes would be a better
way to go
uh the problem right now is that the
political will to enact these rules
changes
is not there and
to the extent it existed when when
emotions were higher
earlier a lot of these state
legislatures and city legislatures
weren't
in session or had adjourned because of
kovid um
so it right now it's an open question
whether there will be meaningful policy
changes
uh nothing from congress i mean that
there was like a
george floyd act on the table that um
got
stalled in the in the senate so that's
one of the things that
that to me is actually like a larger
issue
that is going to break us uh is that
our government's not actually responding
to uh
to just about any expression of
um will or desire for action on the part
of the american people
is that when it comes to brass tax they
get in there and then they say wait a
minute
like i uh i'm going to make
real problems and real political enemies
if i go down this road or
um there are or there are legislators in
uh congress who know they're gonna get
re-elected
uh no matter what because the incumbent
reelection rate's 94 percent
um and maybe their point of view does
not um
you know like uh the majority of
americans
um certainly earlier this summer were
for some form of police reform
um but just the the nature of
legislative incentives
we're seeing with a stimulus bill too
where something like 90 percent of
americans want to send me this bill
uh and politicians are deciding it's
better for their political futures
if they blame the other side and don't
pass a bill
um so so this this lack of
ability to respond and change policies
and adapt on the part of legislatures
in cities and states and in congress
it is going to be an increasingly
intractable problem
um and it's one reason why now i'm i'm
turning my sights towards some form of
um government reform honestly where you
look up and say why is it that
if 80 90 of people think this is the way
to go
uh we don't do that whether it's um
stimulus relief or stimulus uh
stimulus bill for pandemic relief
whether it's
i would throw addressing climate change
in there like the majority of americans
are for that uh and so
you know there are a bunch of things
where uh the
majority of us are foreign and our
government doesn't do anything
and we're getting increasingly
despondent and now
police reform makes that list because
the majority of americans want some form
of police reform
and we're not really seeing it
here's a fact for you is that
it takes longer to be trained to become
a hairdresser
than it does to become a cop in the
united states of america
and that is nothing against hairdressers
my cousin's a hairdresser um
like it's an awesome career particularly
i mean i think they're they're
struggling now a bit but they're getting
back
in covid but it's a 13 to 19 week
training process for our cops um and i
think the situations they are in are so
stressful and life-threatening that to
me
i mean hell man i trained for two months
to become a lifeguard that's all just
just shy of that like it's like to me it
feels like an under resource
investment well there's the time frame
spent but then there's the nature of the
training
so first the training is different
everywhere because you know you have
tens of thousands of police departments
that's true and it's outsourced too a
lot right like governments will
they'll certainly consolidate because
their profit comes to its time yeah i
mean if you're a small
community you don't have your own police
academy so you know it's like someone's
been trained elsewhere
uh but one number i saw was that
um the average law enforcement officer
spends 58 hours
training in the use of their firearm in
deadly force uh
and eight hours in de-escalating
conflict and so
if you're in like an ambiguous situation
you're
prone to speed it up uh and use force
rather than slow it down and try and
de-escalate so so that's a feature of
our training
that um i think leads in a particular
direction the message they're getting
right
yeah the it's all about if they're
learning all about the gun right well
yeah the message is to
uh you know to to um
speed it up and and uh you know
use force in in many circumstances
and it's uh and so that you know there's
like there are different things we could
do
um but it's tough in part because this
is like a very diffuse
problem um and to me
ideally you'd have national use of force
rules
when it comes to law enforcement because
asking each
um city and state to tackle it
might not work uh until after the fact
and even after the fact it might not
work
you know so i think um things like
uh like banning chokeholds and things
that were uh included in the george
floyd act
having better data on what the heck is
going on uh because right now that that
data is unclear
it gets compiled from various
journalistic accounts
um yeah that so the real
problem in my mind now is like why can't
our government or governments
uh get these things done um
and it's in large part because um we've
created these systems that
uh that are almost designed uh not to
get things done
and that the political incentives are
not to take any kind of serious action
and just play it out just play out
politics and like once you're in you're
gonna
stay in uh almost regardless
of how the body performs
um and congress is the most glaring
example of this where they have an
approval rating of 21
and individual members have re-election
rates of 94
so they they know that they're going to
get re-elected regardless of whether
or not people approve of congress's work
more broadly so
for those of you interested in more in
our deeper conversation on police reform
we do have an episode
it was called but what can we do six
ideas for police reform and that came
out on june 8th of this year
i mean it's even more relevant now jeez
um
so you you mentioned i mean democracy
reform
is going to be our jam going forward
and it's you gotta fix the system
here on yank speaks we are all about
your data rights
prop 24 is about to pass in california
thanks to you and it's going to set a
new
new threshold for how our data gets
treated but in the meantime your data is
getting
sold and resold right in the left and
even your internet service providers
know
every move you make so what can you do
you can use
a virtual private network which is what
all the companies
have their employees do and the vpn we
recommend
is the number one rated by cnet wired
and the verge expressvpn
expressvpn it's like you log into a
server
on another continent and no one knows
it's you
no one knows what the heck you did so if
you
want your data to remain secure
expressvpn is what you've been looking
for
secure your online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com
yang today there's a special deal where
you get three months for
free and your subscription that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang
even though our system's so busted and
messed up like i love when you can help
us make sense of what's happening
so last we talked we were talking about
um
we were hoping for a couple republican
senators to
not be hypocrites if you will for what
they did to um
merrick garland uh in 2016 in terms of
waiting until
after the election to nominate um
a supreme court justice mitt romney was
one of the ones we
thought um had a spine and was
definitely center right
and he tweeted out this which i will
read in the
thoughts he says mitt romney from
senator from utah former presidential
candidate
says my liberal friends have over many
decades gotten very used to the idea of
having a liberal court
and that's not written in the stars it's
also appropriate for a nation which is
if you will
center right to have a court which
reflects a center-right point of view
what so two thoughts two questions for
you
one thoughts on romney in general
fall in line with the republicans and
two
thoughts on the country being
center-right uh is that another mitt
romney tone-deaf moment
uh which he was kind of notorious for
and when he ran for president what do
you what do you think man
um he's not the first person to say that
our country is center-right
um and uh it's been true certainly
at various points um whether it's that
way now
you know as the numbers guy i would say
that
uh self-identified independents
outnumber other republicans
or democrats so it would be a matter of
judgment as to
um whether the country is center right
center left
leaning you know one way or another
right or center right that's
yeah yeah i i would say that that's um
that would be fair uh i was disappointed
but not surprised by the fact that mitt
came out
um for a supreme court appointment
because
of the nature of his constituency really
i mean he's a senator from utah
you know that most of his
voters would be very favorable towards a
conservative supreme court appointment
appointment so it would seem like he
would
be going against the will of his
constituents on a matter of principle
and
that seemed like a lot uh you know like
it it made more sense to me that folks
whose political fortunes
um would be uh
helped frankly by going against the
supreme court appointment
um would might make that call so susan
collins is one example where
uh she's in a very tight race in maine
and um
she's being castigated for just being
like a rubber stamp for trump so for her
coming out and saying like hey i'm not
with trump on this one like
is probably helpful to her politically
uh the other person that i had hoped for
was corey gardner
in um colorado i was running against our
friend john hickenlooper
i thought there was a chance that uh so
similar dynamic
gardner gardner's getting thrown under
the bus for being a trump rubber stamp
so i thought there was a chance he'd be
like not with trump on this one but then
he came out and said i am and then
and the interesting thing is like it
struck me as like
an unhelpful move for him politically
like i think that gardner
um is very likely to lose to
hickenlooper and that this announcement
is going to
not help him in that direction um so
big picture you did not get the four
republican senators that you need to go
against
this nomination if trump decides to
nominate and speed it up
then it's going to happen there are very
very limited moves that democrats into
the senate can
make to try and hold this up they can do
things that are
uh a break from tradition in terms of
meeting with the nominee
um but the votes are the votes and so if
you you wind up with 51 people voting to
confirm
um in let's call it october or november
december
then uh then we're likely to see uh
a new supreme court justice by year end
so one hand mitt seems to be relatively
principled guy i know people disagree
with that or have their opinions on that
but um
if you're a republican i mean and you
don't like trump
and mitt is on record not liking trump
at all but he's republican
and he wants a republican justice or
conservative justice on the supreme
court
um so i don't agree with mitt on
everything um
and i know you certainly don't but to me
i can't
i don't blame him for that i was hoping
um
on principle of what happened in 2016
that they would um wait for the election
but
this is why a lot of them it's why
they're why they're there you know this
is but
they want the law of the land um well to
me this has to spur
a drive towards modernizing the court
and this is one of the things i've been
talking about is like look
lifetime appointments do not make sense
uh
the constitution says nothing about the
number of justices a majority vote in
the senate could change the number from
9 to
17 or 27 or whatever the number would be
and there was a plan that i quite liked
which is just a point a new one every
two years
uh and let the number rise all the way
up
to something like 27 and one advantage
to this is that you could actually hear
more cases because right now the supreme
court is this massive bottleneck
where uh they don't hear a whole lot uh
one of the reasons why the supreme court
is such a like a
it seems like such an important um
institution to us is that congress is so
dysfunctional
in theory or even in the not so distant
past
if congress did not like a supreme court
ruling on something it has passed a law
like the supreme court's job is to is to
interpret the law
and so if congress thinks that supreme
court messed up in an interpretation
they were like hey just to clarify this
is what we meant and they just pass a
law
saying this it's just because congress
can't get anything done
that now we're looking up and saying
like oh the supreme court rules all it's
like actually congress gets freaking
right aloft they
like you know if they remembered how to
legislate
so so the supreme court um in my mind
needs to be modernized
having lifetime appointments is just an
awful awful
anachronism um right now in 2020
18-year terms plenty long uh just let
the number rise
uh and make it so that we're we're not
literally having these
uh these
self-inflicted crises because an 87 year
old
fighting cancer had to like hang on
until her dying days and then she like
passes uh
weeks before an election and here we are
i mean like that that's not
a great situation for anybody
uh and and modernization should be
bipartisan because
it's like look you win an election you
get a couple justices
like uh but it should not be that you
uh you nominate someone
and you're like ooh i'm gonna nominate
this young person who's like
only 49 they'll be there for 30 years
like
does that make any sense too it's like
that you're planning a flag and being
like this shall be the law of the land
not to evolve for decades it's like
you're supposed to
actually be trying to have some measure
of um
of uh predictability transparency
let you know that the this this
commentator who i appreciated who
who suggested this plan was like um
was that this perception built up over
time that the supreme court was somehow
going to be apolitical
um but actually like at this point we're
um we're clearly in at a point where
where it's becoming
more and more of a politicized
institution uh
and so let's just like accept the fact
that elections have consequences where
the supreme court is concerned and that
you're not relying upon
um uh uh upon nine unelected
uh lawyers to make
the country's decisions for us uh you
know it's like like that that's
uh that's not the way the framers
envisioned it it's not though it's not
what the people want
uh again a lot of this would would be
better if congress could
pass laws and then you know you'd have
like a responsive body
um but i'm all for modernizing the court
uh which is i i'm going to suggest like
you know
it should be bipartisan because no one
should be happy like right now
conservatives are happy because they're
they're getting these appointments but
you know like you can have dems in
charge like in this case like a matter
of
weeks and so for you having appointments
that don't last forever
like also not a bad thing
to me one a presidential term seems like
the most logical and fair
and simple way to freaking do it because
what happens what seems like to
me is that obama gets
one and or none or trump gets three
obama gets one over eight years and
trump gets two over four
like that doesn't make sense like if you
lose the election
won the term if you stay in for two
terms you get two
and that way um we don't have to count
on people living and dying
um yeah so i'm gonna suggest two a term
because then like you can have them
rotate off
if you only had one one every term then
then like the rotation
uh there's more on there than yeah it's
less of it then that's the other thing
like more of them that's you talk about
this a lot more of them means that
like if you don't like kavanaugh that's
fine because there's 15 other people or
20 other people his vote is smaller
um the average american well the average
american probably couldn't name like
you know like but like the average
american has no idea who's on like the
uh second circuit court of appeals or
whatnot you know what i mean
like and and that is not necessarily a
bad thing
like yeah i'm going i would i would
argue that
like if you had you know like 17
19 27 justices uh
then you wouldn't know who th who they
are and that would be okay you know what
i mean
like like that that's actually probably
a better look
because uh um yeah because
then it's it's less of like a
frankly like this um
it'd be less of like a personality
driven institution um
which right now unfortunately it kind of
feels like
you said something really interesting
that i think is really hopeful um
you said that a senate majority
can increase the number of supreme court
justices right or does it have to be all
of congress or is it just senate that
can approve it
do you know oh it's just a law so
yeah it's just yeah it's just law
it was i believe that the the the nine
the nine justices rule was passed i
believe in something like 1869
and it was just a law oh my gosh so here
here it is folks here's your hope
because to me
i would like roe v wade to state law of
the land um
i think or the precedent of the land i
guess to your point earlier um
so rbg and i know i've talked a lot of
to my female friends who are um and
mothers and my mom
who are a little um concerned about this
if you are
fearful it sounds like the hope is to
vote
and we can freaking back win this back
and adjust our supreme court pass a law
that
hasn't been updated for 100 plus years
um and make the court more dynamic and
more reflective of the american people
and not reliant on literally 86 year old
seven-year-old women men uh staying
longer for an extra year to avoid
a political you know a president whose
political party they don't belong to or
agree with
um so vote because if we take this back
we have a shot to fixing it is that
is that fair to say andrew yes the drive
should be
court modernization it's time to
modernize
uh the supreme court and and that that
to me is the hope
but it requires us to vote
all right um so
i'm going to um we're going to wrap our
episode with a couple um
just quick things one thank you for all
who participated in our um
in the united giveaway we're giving away
um we'll announce that next week next
monday's episode so if you haven't
submitted a caption yet
please do it's on our instagram at
andrew yang and that's zach grauman
um we've got andrew the debates are next
week am i getting that right
or is it september 29th tuesday so it's
going to be the day after this comes
oh this is tomorrow right yeah
so tuesday 29th and andrew yang
is in prime time going to be spitting
hot fire
and dropping bombs on whatever
republican they throw at him or whatever
pundit
that says something stupid andrew's
going to crush them so
even though it's going to be very it's
going to be very collegial because we're
all
oh come on but it's a jump bump for me
man just on him one time
just just in the back of your head just
what you're thinking like i am a crush
this guy real quick just for the youtube
clip
i'll be on i'll be on cnn before and
after the uh the debate yeah um
and it looks like that's that's probably
true for all the debates i think
yeah it's it's exciting um and then
on the most important news i know it
buried the leagues at the end of the
podcast but for those of you listening
um at the time of recording josh allen
leads the nfl in passing yards on the
buffalo bills so i know it's not really
this audience but
i just want to say it's a good good year
bill's fan so far all right
um guys we love you
take a listen to this interview with
annie lowry she was
andrew what she was our first the first
ubi champion right like maybe her and
robert reich like she's the first i
think
she was she's one of the great modern
day
champions of universal basic income and
certainly we all know universal basic
income has been around for decades and
decades but annie
is one of the the chief figures that has
uh rekindled interest in it uh and she
and i met at a universal basic income
panel uh back in 2017.
she's tremendous she's a brilliant
journalist i love reading her stuff
because
she's approaching things from a similar
vantage point around just human beings
and
uh how to improve our way of life and
she figured out universal basic income
before just about anyone
wrote this great book give people money
that came out the same time my book came
out
so if you're looking for a universal
basic income reading that goes
uh into international environments uh
and uh goes goes about it a bit
differently than mine
and she and i talk about this on the
interview where she's like you're like
the technology guy
more like the social program benefits uh
um uh how to better like the way of life
for people um journalists
uh but we're all attacking the same
problems from different angles
uh i'm super grateful to annie i read
her book and learned a lot
uh and i continue to learn from her yeah
she's amazing and you guys yeah there's
a that's the perfect way to put it
andrew you you tag it from like an
automation
tech perspective and she gets there from
a human perspective which you
and and she understands the automation
tech same way you understand the human
side
but it's a fascinating way to look at
something we've been passionate about
for a while
um so tune in guys annie lowry joins
yang
speaks
there are a lot of creative people
listening to this right now i know it
i know the yang gang's filled with
creatives and one of the things about
trying to develop creatively is it
really really helps to have someone
who's further ahead
than you are on that skills chain if you
don't know what i mean you can teach
yourself a lot of stuff
but if you want some classes resources
world-class experts skillshare is the
place to go we have
so many people who swear by skillshare
it's an online learning community
with classes for creative and curious
people
you can do i mean you can't learn
everything but you can learn a lot of
um and frankly with kovid um
i've started to pick up golf a bit but
that's frankly i'm not very
good so i've started to find my like
self-fulfillment in other ways
so um you can learn literally like how
to illustrate
uh filmmaking from home how to be more
productive
um literally like there's like how to
draw different types of faces like it's
artistic
it's life improving it's pretty
fascinating stuff
and we have a special deal for you guys
so if you want to explore your
creativity
get two free months of premium
membership at skillshare.com
yang that's two whole months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for free get started and join today at
skillshare.comyang that's two free
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes
at skillshare.com
it's my pleasure to have on yang speaks
one of my favorite journalists
uh and thinkers in the world annie lowry
hey annie how are you
great thank you so much for having me
i'm so excited to do this
yeah it's so overdue because you're part
of a very
select club of folks who've been
championing universal basic income
since uh let's say before 2019 or the
pandemic
or something along those lines and for
folks who haven't read andy's book give
people money which
hopefully that title says it all as to
what it's about you should definitely
pick it up because
it's a great book about universal basic
income worldwide
i read it and learned a ton from it even
before i launched my campaign
yeah thank you um so much yes we are we
are part of uh
of a a relatively small club here and so
um uh i really appreciate that and
obviously loved your book as well
and i'm happy to chat about you know
whatever it is that's going on now
this unbelievable cluster that we find
ourselves in
yeah these are terrible times you know i
talked to
ezra as you know earlier this week and
he said that it smells like fire
sometimes
um where you all are uh in california
um how are you in the family
i know you have a lot that you're
balancing yeah thank you for asking
um we are doing okay um internally in
the office we describe it as
covid fine like i am personally all
right
i still have my job my husband is doing
fine and
we never got sick we had a fairly
short lapse in child care because our
kiddo he's a toddler he's not in school
yet so we haven't had
as much disruption as a lot of my
colleagues
and your kids are kind of school age
right yeah seven
seven and five so a little bit older
older than yours i guess they guess
their post toddler
yeah post toddler um and so you know
personally been doing okay
um but it's been it's been a really
difficult
thing to watch this year right a
recession that
um is much deeper than the great
recession and i
i worry in some ways will be intractable
and then this
astonishing public health crisis and
then you know these these
other crises that i think are slower
moving but no less urgent that we're not
dealing with having to do with racial
inequality with climate change with
everything else and
a political system that i think is
really struggling to meet the moment in
a pretty profound way
so it's it's um personally okay
horrified literally every day at what's
going on and yeah the state being on
fire it's like oh man
that that that too i don't know how how
are you holding up i'm sure now you
you probably actually maybe have like a
little bit more space for yourself than
you did if we were talking a year ago
but is
is everything okay with you well
certainly a year ago
was it was not the right time for me
though in your case maybe because
you know maybe something uh good would
have come out of it
um so you call it covid fine in the
office uh
uh we call it 2020 good it's like how
are you doing 2020 good
but but but we also are our 2020 good
uh and also horrified on a daily basis
uh as to what's going on
someone called it the omnic crisis which
i think is as good a name as any
uh and one reason i'm excited to talk to
you is that you're someone
who has their finger on the pulse of
what's going on
in the economy more than really just
about anyone there is
one thing i want to share with you very
briefly because you're the only person i
can share this with and i don't think
i've ever
even had this conversation with anyone
um so you and i
uh both had our books kind of reviewed
simultaneously in the new york times it
was like some kind of weird joint joint
review
by robert reich and uh
i i have to say i thought it was just a
really odd review
like where you know it's like so you're
an author you write your book
like you're like oh wow it's getting
reviewed in the new york times very
exciting and then you read it and you're
like i still have no idea what
he said about my book
and so so you're you're the you're the
other um author on that review so i just
wanted to to
make sure i wasn't crazy for thinking
that do you so i'm gonna admit something
i've never read a single review of my
book
i've never looked at sales figures i
like
kind of answer reader emails and that's
it cause i just i decided i was like
i'm not sure that i have the emotional
capacity to see
like post publication reviews and so i
had my husband read them and just let me
know if there was something like
really unfair or something that would be
reputationally damaging
but other than that like i didn't read
the new yorker essay i didn't read the
wall street journal review like i read
none of it
so i'm i'm like here in my blissful
ignorance so i like have no idea what
you're talking about
i know that the review existed but i was
precisely i was like
oh man like i i i'm not sure that i have
the emotional fortitude to
also because i think that i having
written the book i was like
i i have such a harsh critique of my own
work
always and i i was like i would probably
just agree and be like oh yeah they
they weren't actually cutting enough
which is like an internal impulse of
mine
but yeah i'm sure our books are really
different and you and i think about ubi
really differently and so i somehow feel
like
um like our books are like they they
kind of make maybe
like good cousins or something but ubi
is a really vast
topic and it lashes a lot of ideas
together
and so i could very much see that you
know it's it's funny because i think of
us as sort of like
working on different parts of the same
intellectual project but yeah it was it
was like just coincidence that they
happened to come out
pretty close to each other so yeah
that's that's interesting
that's so fun that you had as your
reader
he was like he was like your force field
uh i i have to say i think that sounds
very healthy
if you ever need me to read something
for you online
my services are available for a
reasonable price
if you need if you need a human force
field for your own work
i i think that we have hit upon a
massive
idea here which is that so many of us
need force fields
you can name it after uh your husband
ezra we could call it the ezra
have you have you put out something for
public consumption
and uh you want to just make sure that
there's nothing
um completely untrue and uh malicious
being written about you but you don't
have that you know i think that would be
actually
hysterical like you you could have like
the synthesizer
of all the stuff that is said about some
work of yours
this is a massive business idea or or
non-profit idea it's just a massive idea
yeah i think this is this is a good
multi-billion dollar idea we have here
we can like branch out into stock
puppeting services where like are you
tired of tweeting as yourself like we'll
come and we'll uh we'll we'll tweet for
you we'll do all of this
it's i i think this is great
yes well i certainly envy you um your
ezra
based force field not to say i mean the
review was fine
i don't need that particular thing but
just generally i think it's a very smart
uh human way to metabolize
that sort of thing particularly as
someone who ran for president
and was subject to all sorts of
um comments and critiques
and support and love but it's certainly
a lot
uh and i i think for me
uh i did not realize
what that would be like uh i suppose
there's no one there like there's no way
you could
um i had kind of uh
an unrealistically sanguine attitude
about it
i think when i started i was like
because to me the big uh
the big obstacle was just simply being
ignored
i thought that was going to be like the
main thing i had to overcome
and so the last thing on my mind was
like
vitriol or nastiness online and
there was an extended period when i did
get something negative i'd be like well
at least they're talking about me
like oh it's good yeah that's like the
healthiest attitude i've
i've ever heard it's a thing that i
there are a lot of amazing things
i find about politicians um
like but i think the ability to
um uh to have that level
of attention and to be able to filter
things out
and one thing that i think is
interesting is how does it how does it
how do you
accept good critiques like real
critiques
um and let those in while also
filtering all of the nonsense like i get
probably 1 100 of you get of what you
get just from being like a woman on the
internet let alone a person who
is like on a debate stage and is running
for office
and it's just it's a really difficult a
really really difficult thing
and i've responded by in a lot of ways
especially as i've gotten older and have
felt more secure
in my career just shutting things off
right so like i don't
i don't have facebook um uh i
tweet things out but i can't see
anything on twitter um
it's totally one way i just use it as a
as a megaphone and so the way it's set
up is that ezra has the password and the
two-factor so he just tweets for me
and like but you can't wow you can't do
that as a politician
where you're like answerable to people
and you need to be
communicating with them and and i think
when you want to be convincing
them right like as a politician you
don't want to be in the position of
writing people off
it's really fascinating and i kind of
think that the brain is just not
it's just not organized for it it's a
really tough and i i really admire the
emotional and intellectual fortitude it
takes to do something like that
it's true as a politician you cannot be
inaccessible that way
or at least i couldn't um no no the
origin of my campaign i think
if you're at a particular level then
maybe you can
get away with it or having like a
there's like a corporate
uh account that that your staff
maintains and everyone can tell the
difference
very very quickly yeah um i could i
certainly couldn't get away with that
um and for for folks who feel hurt uh by
what andy's describing i can vouch for
the fact that i was like why does annie
follow me on twitter
and now i know no no no don't
totally totally fine because really when
i was just reaching out to you for this
uh this podcast like that's when i
discovered it because uh you know
i i was like i'll just reach out to her
on twitter um
so but there there is something to the
fact that
i think being a public figure in a
certain way requires there there to be
a degree of permeability and then that
requires you to have a certain
mindset about feedback uh and and i'd
say
to your point annie it's like it's
pretty easy to blow off uh comments that
you know
are are ridiculous or whatever like the
comments that make you think
are the ones that are thoughtful and
like and prefaced by something um
relatively human or humble being like
look you know
like you don't need to listen to me but
um you know like
i saw your last thing and this is what i
thought of it and this is the way like
like that kind of thing um you do
take to heart almost instinctively uh
because if someone took the time to
craft something thoughtful
then as a human being you know you give
it some degree of weight
and care uh yeah so i i'm with you on
that
uh and you end up with like a very quick
filtration mechanism
where if it's thought less then you just
kind of bypass it
uh um so so that that's at least my
reality for what it's worth
yeah that's really it's really
interesting and it's it's good to know
and i say it's interesting because it
does i think you're right right like
in so many ways i think that that
politicians become
immune to um or unable to hear
um constituent problems in kind of funny
ways
um i think that they become kind of
insensitive
to the possibility of change that is out
there and also
just to like the realities of problems
on the on the ground
and that's not like it's painting with a
very big brush but i do
i think that like the whole question of
how you're filtering information and
what you care about
i see this in my own work too right like
i do a lot of just like
listening to people and discarding story
ideas or saving them for later
just like literally trying to figure out
like what is happening in people's lives
and how can i report on that in a way
that's that's true
and how do we have like both a narrative
of like real humans experiencing life
and some kind of evidentiary backing
some data to see what's what's what's
going on out there
um which i think is you know sort of
like a different version of that same
challenge uh that policymakers face well
i love your reporting because it often
synthesizes and combines very human
um emotional stories that you can see
yourself
in with tons of data because yeah you
you're
very very wonky uh and data driven
um before we move on to what's going on
out there and how you
see what's unfolding um what you just
said about politicians
i think is a real problem i've been
trying to figure out how to
fix this broken system of ours because
like you said our government's not
meeting the moment
and you're you're seeing uh failures
right and left
and one of the issues annie and this
was some research that came out was that
i think
being a politician genuinely messes with
your mind yeah and there was that that
reporting about how
power changes your brain wiring so you
become less
apathetic and you reciprocate less and
you mirror less and
you're generally number uh and don't
pick up cues as well
and i can see it like i because i
i'm as most people know a relatively uh
new public figure and so i've been in
the public eye
for a number of months let's say and i
think i'm still pretty much the same guy
i was and like i haven't had my my brain
damaged
but but i can very clearly see if i like
was in this kind of arena
for decades uh how it would end up
changing me in a way that would make me
less apt
to listen to folks or care uh
and i think that this is something that
is
almost embedded in our system because at
this point we have so many leaders
who've been
in the public eye for 20 30 years plus
yeah i mean i think that that's that's
absolutely
astute and when you look at the problems
right like the
gerontocracy of american politics
um i don't necessarily think that that
age and experience or bad things
at all and i i don't in any way mean to
be ageist
but i do think it is problematic you
know it's funny i
i was back reading um for a potential
story i was just
reading coverage of like the 92
96 and 2000 elections
um and people were just so much younger
than politicians were just so much
younger and this was this was true
throughout american life and i
i think you can see it when you look at
congress and the parties also
um and uh you know um
for a piece that i just recently wrote
about the republican party
it's kind of about like why the
republican party has has
moved away from many of its own ideas
has really stopped pushing forward
legislatively and how it's become the
word that i settled on was kind of
contentless
right it's it's sort of a protection
bracket for rich people substance free
substance free yeah self-perpetuating
for the sake of perpetuation
exactly they just want to win and one of
the things that political scientists
brought up is they're like
look like people's tenures are really
long
and politicians you can see it in this
current election tend to be really old
and we know that that really matters a
lot in terms of just like introducing
new ideas in and so i guess that this is
a roundabout way of saying that we need
way more
andrew yangs running for office there
should be more andrew yangs i agree
i'm not sure if my wife would agree
she'd be like what is plenty
yeah we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to clone you i think so
all that that would probably lead to an
asian joke somewhere sorry
i'm sorry if there's like there was like
an army of me
um so so
thank you for that i i've said
on multiple occasions it should not take
someone like me running for president to
get a new idea on the national stage
um so in that regard i agree with you
there should be more people
trying to advance new ideas so we're not
subject to
um like a 20 or 30 year old conversation
yeah yeah i think that that that's
absolutely right and you know i
appreciated that that
one thing that i think is hard about
liberal politics right now
is just that all of the kind of policy
idea generation
is really happening on the left and i
think that there's a lot of desire
for new and big policies and i think
it's going to be really hard for those
to become
a really potent part of the national
conversation
despite the fact that there's just lots
of great ideas out there
and the left has you know as the rate
has gotten sort of smaller and moved
really far to the right the left has
gotten bigger and sort of absorbed this
kind of uncomfortable center while it's
also moved to the left and
i think it's it's going to be really
interesting one of the things that
if biden wins which of course i'm not
sure that that'll happen
at all um is is going to be interesting
is is just to see
you know i think um it's a hard thing
about being on the left right now is is
you know that you're going to be facing
a lot of of disappointment
um just for structural reasons so
yes let's fight to be disappointed
all right listen up i am personally
not a toilet paper guy we're going to
talk about some good stuff i'm not a
toilet paper guy i'm more of a wipes guy
um but i've recently become
a bidet guy now what the hell's a bidet
i never heard of it i hadn't heard of it
until i went
um abroad and they have these in europe
but it's basically this lovely
warm hose
um that you use instead of toilet paper
to wipe your butt
and it's they're extremely popular in
europe because they're cleaner
um you look there's not as much waste
there's less clogging all this good
stuff
and there's a company called tushy
that is making this more accessible and
easy for america
and americans to use so hello tushy is
the modern bidet attachment
um it cleans your butt with a precise
stream of fresh water for just 79 bucks
so it attaches to your existing
toilet no electricity needed no
additional plumbing it cuts toilet paper
used by eighty percent so if even if
you're trying to pinch pennies
this is a save um so the hello tushy
bidet pays for itself
in just a few months i love this because
it's better for the environment
it's modern it's smarter it's efficient
uh it's one of those things where other
countries have figured it out and
americans
are a little bit behind the curve on
this one but we can speed it up
uh and uh that's what we're all about
here in yang speaks
and this is one great way to do it be
kind to yourself be kind to the earth
so the yang speaks listeners gonna have
the cleanest butts in the country
this is a special offer for our
listeners hellotushi.com for 10
off hellotushy.com yang
um so annie you're one of my favorite
reporters
in the world in terms of just seeing
what's out there
uh and i can sense the pain
um in in your voice when you think about
what is going on out there um where it's
your job to
actually talk to people and make sense
of the
the data so as an economics reporter
right now how do you figure out just how
bad the damage is
it's um it's pretty hard this is a
really unusual recession
um it happened really fast it was this
kind of
induced recession for public health
reasons
so we had this kind of soft i don't want
to call it a lockdown because we never
really locked down
but this sort of withdrawal of business
activity that was driven not by the
federal government but
by state and local governments and and
really largely by people themselves
being like
i don't want covid i don't want to
spread covid
i'm going to stay home and and you had a
pretty
impressive i was i was pleasantly
surprised at the cares act
how big it was and how aggressive it was
um but we proceeded to do nothing on the
public health front um
at a federal level and you know we're
nearing 200
000 people dead and now we've had this
really dramatic withdrawal of support
so ppp is over while businesses are
still struggling um the 600
boost is gone in ui so that's taking i
believe it's like 60 billion dollars out
of the economy every month and that's
from tends to be disproportionately
lower income families who are quite
likely to spend it
and so i feel like we're a little bit in
that um
in that circumstance where like you know
the coyote runs off of the cliff and
just is suspended in air for a minute
um that's august
yeah that was august and i feel like
gravity is now going to kick in
yeah and we still you know we have these
eviction moratoria
we've not seen um a ton of evidence of a
sharp decline in consumer spending but
that's certainly coming
and so it's pretty hard but you talk to
people and
people are really frightened and
things are really bad and we are seeing
exactly what everybody thought which is
mass business failure
and that mass business failure is going
to be the thing that will turn this into
something like a depression
because like when your business shuts
down for no good reason
um your employees get laid off you go
through a bankruptcy process
um you know you have some wealth effect
it has that that
that knock-on effect and so i'm i'm
really worried this is this is
really bad and i think it's going to
take quite some
time to claw our way out of this
um and i think other countries have
certainly done better on the health
front
i think that they've also done better on
the econ front um
and the fact that we never really got
control of the virus is
is you know culprit it is the alpha and
omega of why everything is terrible at
the moment
yeah you reference the fact that people
are going to make the choices they make
um and it's one of the things i find so
frustrating about some of the
discussions that if
a governor or the feds
make a decision about businesses in a
locality
or travel restrictions or the the lack
thereof
there are still going to be millions of
americans who just look up and say you
know what
i don't think i am going to take that
trip i don't think i am going to go to
that restaurant i don't think i am
necessarily
going to uh hit the bar the movie
theater or whatnot
uh and and so that set of choices will
just have
these long lasting ripple effects for as
long as the virus
uh is out of control uh and as someone
who's run businesses myself
you know right now your appetite for
uh or risk expansion
expenses is so negative right now
that i can see how that's just going to
cascade through the economy when people
start thinking okay like i've given it a
little bit of time and now i'm going to
have to actually start making
the difficult decisions the layoffs the
adjustments
yeah i think that that's right um you
know if you just
take the kind of capital investment
portion of the economy
the hip there alone is probably enough
to
reduce output over a course of of years
um how are businesses supposed to to
plan for the future
if the virus is still spreading and
schools are still still shut down and
everybody's still really afraid of this
and
and you know now we're coming into flu
season and people are going to be
indoors
um it's it's a really impossible
situation that we've put people
in and you know and and i think that
this is
um the the catastrophe is being born on
the back of service workers low-income
workers in general
um you know and in terms of the the
really negative stuff on the horizon
we knew that there was going to be huge
problems with state and local spending
lo and behold like we're starting to see
those layoffs and those pay cuts come
through
um so that's just buying us a longer
recession and
it's really frustrating because i think
a lot of the issues here are amenable to
policy solutions
and we are not both both congress and
the white house are just electing not to
not to rely on those solutions um and
this is this is going to be
this is so bad and i felt like we had
learned some
lessons from the great recession in
terms of just spending your way out of
it and just not
stopping until you you saw wage growth
down in the bottom
of the income spectrum and um
and employment growth kind of across
across um
educational bands and in different
racial groups and all over the country
and
you know it's just we we didn't really
learn those lessons um and and
so this is this is a real it's a real
mess um and again i think that that the
data is not caught up to people's lived
experience just in terms of how bad this
is right now
when you talk about the data um what do
you
look at i mean for me i'll tell you i
look at the
weekly uh unemployment filings yep
um and and try and keep up with what's
going on
in terms of the labor market damage um
one of the
stats that i cited in my dnc speech
which i think really
is very powerful and telling is that
approximately 42 percent of the jobs
that
are being lost right now will not return
yes and i
one reason why i hit that point so hard
is that there are a lot of people i
think that are
waiting for things to quote unquote go
back to normal yeah
and we need to get used to the fact that
what we're seeing right now is actually
closer to the whatever new normal is
going to be
than what existed pre-covid um
so what uh what numbers are you looking
at
and what are they telling you about
what's going on
yeah so um one of the numbers that i
think has been unusually
important during this recession and this
crisis
has been um looking at spending on debit
cards that are linked to the ui
system right so um uh spending is a
little bit
sticky um it takes a while for people to
kind of change their spending habits
in relation to a shock and so one thing
that
that that has been interesting is that
it looks like sort of overall credit
card spending and consumer spending
held up for a little while after the
withdrawal of those 600
um additional weekly benefits on ui
which have now expired and states are
sort of scrambling to set up the
additional funds that the trump
administration um
pushed out through fema and um but if
you look at the actual spending
um that is on debit cards that people
receive ui payments on it just fell off
a cliff
of course it did right like the money
went away and people stopped spending it
and so one thing that's been interesting
during this this crisis has been that
um i feel like it's been more important
to look at some of these private sources
of high frequency data to see how things
are changing in real time
and the hard thing about that is that
you know it's not adjusted and it can be
a little bit murky it's not as solid as
those government numbers
but things have been changing so fast in
just the past six months
that it's been i feel like necessary to
take a look at these at these somewhat
quirkier
high frequency sources of data to get a
sense of what's happening
um because you know i know at this point
it might not feel this way
sort of six months or seven months into
the pandemic but
everything is going really quickly um
for
a recession right like it's it's all
happening really
fast and much more violently than it did
before
um there was like this really big
stimulus but then it ended too
quickly and you know so so it's been
hard to kind of like wait for
a lot of the really big government
numbers come out quarterly right and
they get readjusted you know so
yeah yeah you can't have that it's all
really backward-facing
so the when you talk about this high
frequency private data
um i'm pulling something up on my phone
uh i have a
friend who um runs a clearinghouse for
gig workers over two million gig workers
and yeah
plugged into their bank accounts
essentially so you can see what's going
on
on a weekly basis is this the kind of
thing you're talking about yeah exactly
so um everything that um
everything that that that that is giving
us that kind of like look at what
households sort of broken down
on our um are spending
um yeah so debit card data credit card
data
sites that do sort of job postings have
been really important so yeah
all of all of that has been quite useful
yeah job postings make sense
um so this person's clearing house
um showed that
in august there was a 17 drop in total
income across all members
and that was likely because these
benefits evaporated
um he also said that the number of gigs
that you could sign up for
has gone down by about 60 percent uh
relative to the pre-pandemic number of
opportunities
so those are pretty terrible numbers
certainly the 60
fewer opportunities is awful um and the
17 job of total income is pretty
disastrous too
um given that that that really just got
started in august
um when the benefits elapsed
yeah so that's that's really really
terrible happening here is that we're
starting to see
um uh layoffs that are
to um any kind of like you know initial
shutdown right the layoffs that are
happening now feel like they're more
permanent
um and there's still a ton of them right
like
the weekly layoff number the new new
unemployment claims number has remained
really really high
um for months and months and months now
and i think that we're starting to see
um layoffs become more permanent which
was something that we
we had expected um to happen for quite
some time
so when you're looking at the i mean i
i'm terrified by these numbers too annie
i i feel like you and i
have a lot of similar uh perspectives
and sense of things uh and it's
horrifying what's going on in the labor
market uh it's horrifying what's going
on in these households uh you can
sense this uh desperation and suffering
that's just going to increase
uh really with no end in sight until we
get another stimulus package
and i was talking to ro khanna uh
the member of congress from california
about why the heck we
can't see uh stimulus bill and he was
talking about the dynamics of
congress really that you know you need
um
i mean in this case the house passed
their
heroes act i believe the top line for
that was 3 trillion or so
and then they were just unable to hammer
out a deal with mitch mcconnell and they
all
came home in august and
i sent something out saying look every
day we don't get a deal is
disastrous and it sounds like you have a
similar perspective
yeah absolutely so i mean i feel like um
one thing that is happening is that the
the kind of critical number for congress
um for the federal government
is not that sort of top line how much
money are you spending
right it's it's this gap it's the gap
between
what the economy could be doing um
absent the pandemic and the shutdowns
um and and what it is doing and you need
the federal government to fill that hole
however big the hole is right like this
is the whole
notion of keynesian stimulus and so
you know so how so how big is the hole
annie like how big
how much do you think what do you think
they should be uh filling yeah i don't
think that three trillion
which is um the number that they they
settled on in the heroes act is
is that far off even though they've
already spent the 2.2 trillion in the
cares act
it doesn't matter they need to spend
whatever it is
um will will bring that that that
overall number up
and they can they can do it in the most
effective way possible
so so um we have really good
measurements of this thing called the
fiscal multiplier which is for every
dollar of deficit spending how much more
does that dollar get spent in the
economy or how big is the impact of it
i love it you do something like tax cuts
it's a pretty small impact
you do something like sending people
with no cash cash and it's a really big
impact so unemployment insurance is one
of the most effective ways to do this
i'm just sending people cash is a great
way to do it
things like payroll tax holidays are
really bad and inefficient way to do it
so you need the number to be really big
and you want it to be weighted to things
that are heavily effective at fighting a
recession
and instead congress is just like
sitting on their hands and not doing
anything
and and we are going to see evictions we
are going to see job losses we are going
to see business closures we are already
seeing them
this is happening and and we know why
it's happening and we are seeing it
happen in real time
and the time that they needed to start
passing the stimulus was like months ago
not not now and we still don't have the
bill
and and it's creating tremendous
uncertainty as you point out
because what what what business owner is
going to be investing right now who is
sure of the future
if the future is involving this much
unnecessary death and
economic destruction yeah and who's
hiring
uh in this environment too to your
earlier point
another thing that has really good bang
for the buck
is uh aid to states and cities is that
right
absolutely yeah so they take that money
and they use it
to like pay elementary school teachers
um and for public health and yes it's
it's really really important and so the
issue here is that
states and cities generally need to keep
their budgets balanced and they have
usually quite small sort of rainy day
funds
and so once you see property taxes
and real estate sorry in sales taxes
once that revenue is declining as it is
right now
states and cities are put in the
position of having to lay people off
and so laying off firefighters laying
off teachers laying off sanitation
workers laying off public health workers
you don't want them to do that during a
recession and we have no
automatic way for the federal government
which deficit is the one that can
deficit spend as much as it wants
to fill the gap this was something that
people talked a lot about after the
great recession
and so instead we're in this horrible
place of requiring congressional action
to fix a problem that everybody has
known about
for however long now the
the i can sense your frustration i'm
frustrated so many people listening to
this too
have uh become just fed up with our
uh leaders inability to act and do the
basics
uh and there's a pandemic which we are
handling terribly uh i think that that's
pretty clear to most everyone
um and then there's the compounded
economic damage which we are also
handling terribly and that like these
two things together they
they make people so um
distraught i mean i'm distraught and
angry
over this state of affairs i feel like
uh i feel like your
post at the atlantic is is one of like
the more influential ones and then i
feel like most of the
people in the know read the atlantic i
don't know if that's true that's just my
perception
um and your side too i mean i read your
work and i i can feel like there is this
beating heart of an agenda
behind the urgency you're trying to
to heighten over the level of economic
distress
yeah absolutely um this is this is a
crisis
um and i have some
i don't know why um
the sense that it is a crisis and
we should be acting with absolute
urgency is not necessarily something
that that
all people in the political system share
i certainly think that many
do and are screaming their heads off and
banging their heads against the wall
um to try to get things done um
but i do think that it's an argument for
um having more automatic stabilizers
and taking uh responsibility out of the
hands of congress which is a very very
broken
institution i also i mean i have a
theory
that i it's just a theory um and i have
no evidence for this
but this recession the pain of this
recession has been so
concentrated among lower income workers
who tend to be more disenfranchised in
our political process
um we've already seen wealth recover to
roughly where it was
um before the recession and the pandemic
and just a lot of the economic pain
hasn't been focused up at the top
and i do worry that that's maybe part of
what's going on here is you know the
unemployment rate for people who were
making a lot of money before highly
educated is actually
not that high it's gone up but but but
um it's been much much much much higher
for kind of
service workers um workers who might
happen to have less education
um or who might have been sort of
marginalized in the economy for a bunch
of other reasons to begin with
um and i feel like you know for high
income folks this has now
become about the issue of what do you do
with your kids which is a really really
stressful and important issue but um the
disproportionate burden
of of the health crisis and the economic
crisis
is is really being um born by the people
with the least capacity to manage it
and so i i don't know i i get the
feeling that that might be part of
sort of the perceptual shift here um but
again i
i don't necessarily know that oh i'm
sure you're right
annie because if you look at and i'm
very self-conscious about this so during
this pandemic i've been
doing as much work as i can do to try
and help we've distributed eight million
dollars to folks in increments of
between 250 and three thousand dollars
uh you know i've been
campaigning for various candidates but
i'm very self-conscious of the fact that
i'm on zoom a lot and i interact with
other people who are on zoom
and all of the airline attendants and
bartenders and security guards
and personal trainers and hairstylists
and
folks that relied upon their physical
proximity to
their job and have a job um most of them
are suffering
in some way right now and i i'm unlikely
to see them on zoom or i'm unlikely to
see them
you know on on my um
my events or whatnot and i'm very very
conscious of that and unfortunately i
think that's informing
our politics i think it's informing in
part the journalistic coverage as well
because
if you're a journalist uh you know there
are limitations as to
um how you can identify and speak to
to various people and actually lay out
the the data in a way that's
intelligible to readers or viewers yeah
i think that that's right
um and i do i think you know the child
in
child care and educational crisis um
the fact that we have failed so many
people and we've
handicapped our economy in in such a
profound way
and it's you know it feels like a moral
failing too um
it's one of the things that makes me
this is i feel like this entire podcast
is like things that make annie angry
but that's one of them too it's really
hard to talk to um folks in other
countries where the schools are open
and life has really returned to normal
whereas here
um you know people are are still really
struggling and not going out and wearing
masks and it's still really frightening
and
you know um uh that that part of it it's
not to diminish any of it
um but yeah that's a it's a different
set of issues and
and you know and and i guess one of the
frustrating things is how many families
are
facing both right both the job loss and
the loss of child care
or you know you have to leave your kids
at home because you have to go to your
work that you don't want to but
because it's unsafe but like you have no
choice and so
um yeah it's it's the impacts have been
felt very differentially
if you're listening to yang speaks you
like podcasts so thank you for that
uh but you also like learning from
people
who have done something become expert in
something and one great podcast for that
is the jordan harbinger show
where he brings on folks who
have become world class at something and
then he doesn't just let them talk about
how cool they are he actually tries to
get into the guts
of how they do what they do so you can
pick up
how a cinematographer makes their magic
how some of the greatest investors in
the world actually make decisions
uh how that guy from catch me if you can
conned so many people for years
so if these stories and the people
behind them
sound like that they would fascinate you
and edify you then the jordan harbinger
show
is the podcast for you this show
so one jordan's a pretty smart guy but
his guests are awesome he's got
he has amanda knox on there recently
who's actually coming on this podcast
soon which i'm excited about but
investors like ray dalio he just had an
astronaut on to talk about i mean what
perspective
um an astronaut gets from once they come
back to earth he had guy razon from how
i built this who i'm a huge fan of
and a big fan of that show so um and
then there's also a lot of practical
stuff that jordan teaches you so
how to fire somebody you care about is
an episode or things like how do i work
with
deal with my mother-in-law um so there's
a lot of crazy but
practical realistic stuff and you can
check it out
um wherever you can find podcasts so we
really enjoy the show and thank you
as well so search for the jordan
harbinger show
that's h a r b as in boy i n as in nancy
g e r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts
the jordan harbinger show check it out
we're fans you guys will be fans too
uh so ezra had me
intrigued when he said that you may be
working on something or working on
something big
uh and so he nudged me to ask you so i'm
now going to
ask you are you so the thing that came
to mind for me is that new book but it
might but it sounded like it might be
something else
yeah i mean so i'm working on a bigger
project that i'm really
excited about um which is
looking at the ways in which
um our safety and this actually grows
out of the last book um
our safety net um uh
was sort of described it was constructed
to be difficult to use
and lo and behold when you head a real
crisis in which people need to use
benefits um or safetynet programs
right so ui something like that or snap
um that then it you know the systems
can't contain these people
um and just in general i think that that
the government
is dysfunctional for a lot of reasons
but one of the ways in which the
government is dysfunctional
is that um it doesn't have a very good
customer service orientation uh things
like doing your taxes are really
confusing so miserable
yeah why right um we have this
enormously over
complicated health system in which you
have to fight with an insurer
and you have to figure out you know does
your doctor take that or the other
it's horrible and the government is
crucial in that and then you you look at
programs like snap or ui
and they're just a disaster and for this
piece i was talking to some folks who
um work on these kinds of systems in
uh like finland and they were just
horrified that you might wait
three months for ui benefits here it's
like literally unheard of there
and and so um that's that's one thing
that i've really been thinking about a
lot this year
um because i think it's in in a lot of
ways intentional
right we don't want the government to
work very well um
or at least a lot of people i want it i
want it to work well annie
you do historically many politicians
have thought that these should be
punitive programs that they shouldn't be
ones that are easy to access or to use
and and
and it's um you know pretty
paternalistic like well
you know if you're unemployed and you
need help from the state then you should
have to
go to this office and figure it out we
don't want to make it to it's a famous
paul ryan
line right like we don't want the safety
net to be a hammock um
but but i think that that you can kind
of back out and just see
how little administrative capacity the
federal government has at this point
and the states that are administering
federal programs and it's pretty
horrifying and it's a really hard
problem to measure
but it's like very obvious to everybody
who ever interacts with any of these
systems
oh we all heard the horror stories of
people getting busy signals for
days and weeks on end because they're
trying to call their
uh state unemployment office and the
obvious question
in my mind was why the heck you have to
call someone to get your benefits like
what is going on here
you know like there should be myriad
ways for you to access those benefits
that do not
involve your uh getting frustrated
dialing in and every time you call and
get that busy signal
it's an erosion in public trust yes you
know like
we're we're conditioned uh to think that
things are supposed to be this lousy
and it's awful uh so you're writing a
book about why
things were designed to be lousy is that
i'm working on a story on it now right
um
and and it yeah it's about um it's about
how it came to be that the the
administration
that public administration became the
burden of individuals instead of the
government
because i think that that's functionally
what happened um and i think that
there's absolutely no reason for it it
was a colleague was asking me
um why is it that unemployment isn't
automatic so as soon as you lose your
job in a layoff you don't just
get unemployment and i was like well
because we've designed it not to be
automatic
like there's absolutely no reason that
it couldn't be automatic
um and the same thing for a lot of these
these programs right like
why isn't it that if you are a parent
with low income
who has a new kid that you don't just
automatically get a payment from the
government
to support that kid's nutrition and to
make sure that you have child care
other countries do that we don't um and
so
i think that this really grew out of
my thinking about this really grew out
of the last book where
where one of the cool things about ubi
is it just vaults over a lot of these
problems um but absent ubi there are a
lot of fixes that other governments have
taken
lots of updates that other governments
have made um
and i think that there's like an obvious
the role of the republicans and all of
this is a little bit more obvious
but one thing that i think is especially
fascinating
is that it's not like blue states are a
lot better on this front than red states
right um
they have a lot of issues with
administrative complexity
um california has had an absolute
disaster with its ui system
and people waiting months and months and
months for benefits and
the problem is is really systemic and
multi-causal and
it touches all sorts of um programs
you know when you talk to people who are
applying for asylum
or people who are formally incarcerated
and you know
um uh are still involved in the judicial
system it's all the same thing
right it's just endless red tape in a
really profound
way this this to me is the
issue annie that you me ezra anyone else
can just freaking beat the drum on this
stuff because
uh everyone can see that our government
is highly inefficient at delivering
various things
to people and we are conditioned to
think that's the way it it
supposed to be even though it's not
supposed to be that way
and it hamstrings uh the
ability for progressives to effectively
uh both win policy changes and argue
for a bigger role of government in
improving our lives in my opinion
because
even reasonable folks can look up and
say wait a minute
like it you know it's like you couldn't
get me unemployment benefits for
weeks or i still haven't gotten them i
mean i hear these horror stories
on twitter all the time where people
like still haven't gotten them and it's
september or whatnot um so we need to
actually start paying attention to the
mechanics like the nitty-gritty
it's one reason why you and i both like
universal basic income because i thought
well if we champion a way to get value
into people's hands then
and it's uniform and it's universal then
we're going to figure out a way to
actually get people that money and of
course if everyone was intending that
money you know you know that they'd be
like
they'd be like where's my dividend and
it ends up
um uh building our capacity to actually
add value in people's lives because you
would have to figure out the plumbing
yeah absolutely um and i think that
there's there's a bunch of win-win wins
here
right if things are simple and automatic
uh you don't need a bunch of civil
servants to administer it
right um and you can free the government
up to do other things
um and we actually we there's a ton of
political science
research there's a a really great
scholar at cornell
named jamila mishner and a lot of her
work is focusing on medicaid
and people's interaction with the
political system after
after receiving medicaid or working with
the health system in general
and and you know one of the things that
comes out of that
is that in many ways interacting with
our government
reduces our interest in and confidence
in government as you put it
and and there's even some evidence that
it sort of dissuades people from voting
and disconnects them from the political
process no way they're like i want
nothing to do with this
exactly and i think that there is this
really interesting kind of like thought
loop that you get in in which like
public services are terrible and it
erodes your confidence in government
and then it becomes self-justifying
right like why would we want to put any
more administration into this if the
government can't get anything right
and i think that you can look at sort of
positive cases of where the government
does get stuff
right like actually most people who have
medicaid are pretty happy with
it i'm old enough to remember when the
argument about medicaid was that it
wasn't insurance worth having
but it is insurance worth having and
people actually really like it people
are very happy with medicare
people are very happy with social
security people are very happy with
public libraries for instance
um so like shouldn't we be setting that
standard shouldn't everything be as
efficient and transparent and
non-punitive
non-paternalistic as social security
right like this is the argument for for
ubi
but you can you can make other changes
um
to sort of nudge you in the direction so
one change that i think we don't talk
about very often but i think would be
really good
is that i think tanf which is our cash
welfare program should be eliminated
and replaced with a child grant right
you should not have to apply you should
not have to
um you know meet these really onerous
terrible work requirements
you shouldn't have to interface with
with
a welfare office that in many cases um
might might have some preconceived
notions about you if you if you are a
person
with with a kid we should just give you
the help right
um and and we should take away all of
the red tape and the judgment and the
everything that goes with it um
and so i think that that's probably the
clearest case um tanf is a really
unworkable
punitive terrible program um depending
on which state you're you're in
um and and it's also not big enough
right like it doesn't
um actually help enough people poverty
because it's been capped at this amount
since 1996 uh the same the same
um amount uh gets appropriated for it
every year
um and so big yeah i think as a general
point like making government work for
people
is is not necessarily a focus of our
political system but it really should be
it really needs to be and we need a
catchy name for this
i've got a couple of trial balloons
one could be the smart state the
efficient
state efficient government yeah
and annie when i had conversations with
folks on the trail about
these ideas i'll tell you like that
republicans
are all over it uh where they're just
like yes wasting government it's
terrible like you need to clean it up
democrats are also all for it but they
consistently
veer straight to the military budget
they say yeah like we spend way too and
which we do i mean you know
we're spending 700 billion uh a year um
but to me this is uh the crux of
an argument or a movement that could
unify people because if you just went
around said look i'm just gonna make
things
work better i'm gonna make it so that
your
interaction with government resembles
your interaction with your bank
where where the site is clean it's like
and you have an app and
you expect things to work right 98 of
the time
and if you and they don't work right
then you can get a remedied pretty
straightforwardly most of the time
um like that has to be the movement um
and that could help bridge this gap
between
it's not like you know big small it's
just better or smarter or more totally
yeah i think that that's really
important that that when we think about
big government intrusive government
bloated
government um you can actually think
about kind of
uh two different axes here right
so one is like how how big is the
benefit how generous is the benefit
but another is like how efficient is the
government in getting it to you
um how much of a royal pain in the ass
is it for you
to to try to get something that they
that you've been told that you
um qualify for that is supposed to be
there for you
and so it's going to be yours yeah it's
supposed to be yours after you walk
through a circle of fire or whatever
we set up this circle of fire for you if
you can get it that it's yours it's like
some kind of strange contest
totally and what's weird is that we have
these these unbelievably
meager benefits in many cases that you
you you need to jump through a thousand
hoops right it's like
you've had some trauma or some difficult
thing in your life and we ask you to
take the sat over and over again
it's complete madness and so and if you
look at countries that do really well on
this so the countries that that have
really excellent public administration
um
uh it tends to be the the nordic
countries
but what's funny and and like
researching this is that
in in fact actually a lot of really low
income countries do great
too because they don't have these legacy
systems they just
their their impetus is to get benefits
to people as fast as they can
and with the as much agility as they can
and so it's it's like we actually have
something to learn
from civil servants in countries like
bangladesh and rwanda
um we are we are uniquely terrible on
this front where where we really
um have this kind of like built up uh
administrative state where we just ask a
lot of people and it's really confusing
and difficult
i love it annie i can't wait to see this
piece and unfortunately if you tell
americans that we could learn something
from bangladesh
they just nod and say yeah probably
um i will say when i was on the trail
i would argue for single-payer health
care
or universal health care and then
someone would come to me and say hey
andrew i understand the need
um but i remember when the government
rolled out medicare.gov and it was a
fiasco it's like you know
taking over healthcare seems even more
complex than that like why do you have
confidence
and you know that that's frankly like a
reasonable question to pose
if you get it if you get it from someone
and i i still you know believe that we
need to
make big moves in the healthcare
provision but
the but skepticism is warranted
uh you know if you're a reasonable
observer and citizen who interacts with
the government
when people just seem to be arguing for
more and more and more
um without actually the
discipline or sense of reality to try
and
address the plumbing like it makes a it
just makes it less credible
yeah i think that that's right and i
think it actually goes to something that
we were kind of saying before
um you know the the thing about a
single-payer system
is that you are eliminating an entire
layer of middlemen yeah tens hundreds of
thousands of insurance workers right now
that are trying to sort through various
uh
um claims and treatments exactly and so
it it does um increase complexity in
some ways
but if the government is is is taking on
that complexity and you're taking
complexity away from consumers
um i think that that could be a good
thing there's the the endless question
of kind of how you get there um but uh
there are other high-income countries
that have transitioned
to more rational systems of care um
in the last 20 or 30 years um so i don't
think that the fact that you you're
gonna have a lot of clutch and a lot of
pain
um doesn't doesn't give you um you know
a reason not to do it
and it does feel like um you know if you
have the north star of kind of universal
coverage but you just want to
rationalize the system
there are just a lot of ways to do that
and i think that the conversation has
become
really advanced but i do it's one of the
constant complaints that i hear about
the aca
and i know that it's it's something that
that that
people have said is you know like a lot
of compromises were were made in order
to get that bill passed
is that it's just a really cludgy
awkward way of doing things
right like we expanded medicaid but
obviously many states continue to opt
out of the medicaid expansion
we have this sort of like extremely
complicated system of exchanges it's
very unclear what you get
and then we have this employer based
system
which is you know remains the primary
system of insurance for prime age adults
and
and for many children and it is just
hugely hugely complicated and irrational
um and it's it's yeah it's an absolute
beast
it's it's really hard and and i do you
know the thing about single-payer
systems
um is that they have an elegance to them
right it's just the nhs is pretty
straightforward
um uh uh compared to what we have which
you look at the org chart and it's just
massive right
massive complicated um system with with
many bureaucratic layers
yeah this is maybe the beginning of a
movement annie around
smart and efficient government and uh
like that this to me has to be
the challenge because we're all seeing
our government fail us in various ways
we need to do more and we need to do it
better smarter and more efficiently
the big challenge to me is trying to
restore
government capacity but also public
trust because right now
last i checked i think congress's
approval rating was something like ten
percent or
probably like literally like 90
disapproval i mean like if you can
imagine a world where we tried to
reverse that and and got
approval up to i mean you probably can't
get 90 but even if you go from
uh 10 to 50 that would be an enormous
accomplishment
and you have to imagine what we'd have
to do to
restore public trust um to me something
like universal basic income
would be a game changer because as
someone who campaigned on it people
uh would find it to be too good to be
true but honestly
just like millions of americans when
they got that 1200 stimulus they were
like wow this is great i
i quite liked that yeah i mean i think
that that's right and i think that
looking at the things that
um government does do well um
right like again people really like
social security that's a program that
that works really efficiently
um people really like the post office um
which i think is why you've seen so many
people
come to save the post office yeah i
i i almost hate to admit this but i had
a really great experience at the dmv
this week we made progress on some of
the dmvs
yeah yeah i was really expecting the
worst and i waited in line for
you know it was probably like half an
hour and they did temperature checks and
everybody had a mask and then i was in
and out of there in five minutes
and so i think recognizing that the
government can be and in many cases in
other countries is an excellent provider
of services
um and then just demanding more of it
right why should you have to wait on the
phone
for you know weeks and weeks and weeks
and make hundreds of phone calls to get
the ui benefits
um that in some cases you paid for with
your fico with your payroll taxes
um why why is it that so many of these
things are
so slow and so cludgy um i really i like
this the you know the efficient the
agile
uh the functional government uh is is
great
and there's so many civil servants who
who really do heroic
work and so many programs that really
work so well
now that we we need to help i mean i may
be in position to help myself
um which i would do because you know
like i see the needs very
clearly um so as one of the the champ
and
so you know i'd endorse the idea of you
turning this article into a full-fledged
book
i think it'd be great to end up being a
resource for us all
you could give it out to folks in
government and hopefully help us improve
things
uh so uh as one of the
foremost early uh champions of a version
of universal basic income and you talked
about how you see
uh you and me as kind of tackling
different parts of the project
first what did you mean by that and
we'll end this on asking
how you see the future of universal
basic income here in the united states
yeah so um i i feel like you have a lot
more knowledge of like what's going on
with
with uh tech than i do and i feel like
it seems to me that
you came to ubi um through
tech but then also just became like a
generator of a bunch of big ideas about
government
i've always really liked your emphasis
on on uh
like mental health and counseling as
being something that we should you know
create more public provision of for
instance
um but i came to ubi like less from
less from a space of of worrying about
technology and and its effect on the
economy
and and and much more from um doing a
lot of reporting on
on uh safety net programs in the united
states which is really where a lot of my
work has been so that was that was all
that i meant from that
but ubi it it has this really
fascinating way of
you know there are people who come from
sort of like a philosophical and a
rights perspective
there are people who come from like a
like um
you know an anti-inherited wealth
perspective which i've always found
fascinating
right like shouldn't every child start
off life with sort of like the same
the same benefits um and i i
i think there's a lot of people who come
from sort of like a green perspective
there's really interesting thoughts
about ubi
and racial justice um and it's one of
the things that i think is kind of
coolest about ubi is that it it just has
a lot of really interesting economic and
philosophical strands
and so in terms of thinking about ubi
going forward
um uh we had this really amazing
thing happen in the spring where one of
the main pillars of recessionary
response that we had from the government
was cash
like we just tossed cash out the window
at people and and it worked great
um and i think that i learned a few
things from that so the first is that it
would be really good if the government
set up a system
to deposit money into bank accounts or
debit cards
get a pipe into my bank account exactly
do
it and i i know that i'm sure that you
know this
it was like gosh it was like 10 or 12
years ago that britain decided to do
this
other countries have like figured out a
way to be like okay if we just want to
get cash out to everybody and we want it
to happen fast how does that happen
there's a million ways of doing it
people talk about fed accounts or postal
banking
um or you know just creating that
relationship somehow
but um it would be really great if if we
could do that so that's that's one
takeaway
and it should be quick right um yes
we're gonna cash out you the money
that's what i'm talking about yeah
serious cash app for all
cash app for everybody it's it's we we
are there and the system should be
really really fast
and really agile and we should be able
to do it and the second
is that um if if giving people
cash to get them out of a moment of
crisis and to help heal
the economy during a moment of crisis
makes sense for a recession
doesn't it make sense for other forms of
crises um
child poverty is a crisis like can we
not see that as a crisis and use
cash to get our way out of it is there a
lot of problems that cash does not fix
but like people having too little money
is not one of them
yes poverty is the absence of cash
yes yeah exactly and so um
that's that's that's what i took away
from that and
i do think that going forward um simple
simple cash rate cash app for everybody
should be a main pillar
of recessionary response and it should
hopefully be automatic so that it's not
congress that has to
approve it every single time i love it
the stabilizer
if the economy teeters then we all get
ourselves
um a dose a recharge in the cash app
that's connected to our bank account i
love it annie it's a beautiful vision
let's make that happen we're gonna make
it happen
i i really hope so i think i think we
need it um
uh it's it's for all of these problems i
can think of a thousand
that would be good if we solved them in
this way well annie you are
a force for good uh and a voice of
reason
i love your work if anyone wants to see
what annie is seeing
go to the atlantic read her work she
posts a new article
every week or two and i'm a subscriber
to the atlantic
i find their journalism to be really
spot-on perceptive smart
balanced rational and all those words
could it could apply to you annie
uh thank you so much and all the best to
you
and the family uh out west i hope you
guys uh
enjoy the end of the summer thank you so
much and i really appreciate
um uh having a chance to to come on and
a chance to chat with you again and
hopefully hopefully the next time
we talk things will be uh a little bit
less of a crisis but
uh really really happy to be here yeah
annie and keep me posted on this piece
and definitely this book we'll have you
back on we'll have you back on when it's
book time that's for sure it's going to
be like a blueprint for
how we can uh fix the plumbing awesome
yeah that sounds great
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you